please be upstanding for the chairman of
the council
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
the council I'd like as always to remind
you could you speak directly into the
microphone from a short distance away
otherwise it won't be picked up I would
also like to remind you that this is a
live recording so that this is going out
live - on YouTube as we speak we would
normally start with the that the
Chairman's chaplain the Reverend
Nicholas Chesterton reading prayers for
the reasons why there are so few of us
today I suggested she should not join us
but she has emailed a prayer which I'm
now going to read out on her behalf
Heavenly Father we come to you today
asking for your guidance wisdom and
support in our meeting and the work we
do we pray for the communities of which
we are a part and which we represent
thank you for those present who have
made it here today and for our
colleagues who work from home we pray
for the safety and good health of all
our counselors Council and civil service
staff and their families during this
difficult time we thank you for all that
they are doing for our communities we
pray for the health and safety of all
give us all courage at this time - what
is advised and acquired to limit the
severity of the outcome of corvid 19 we
pray for those who are afraid lonely or
sick in body mind or spirit we pray for
all medical staff and those ensuring
that food is available for all those
providing necessary necessary services
such as electricity water sewage refuse
and the media that allow people to
remain in
homes give us courage and hope in these
difficult times
our men please be seated
ladies and gentlemen and I'm going to
suggest as we are few in number that the
rest of the meetings can conducted with
people sitting down I could call on the
deputy chief executive to report on the
attendance at this extraordinary meeting
Thank You chairman due to the current
pandemic situation the government
guidance on social gatherings which
sought to limit attendance in today's
meeting so that we have a core of
meeting that reflects the political
balance of the council so the for this
reason we could have rather more
apologies than normal for the minutes
all our readouts the the apologist so
they can perform any record it we've
received a politician counts for Tony
Dixon counselor Louie Allen Adham couch
Victoria Allcock hence the joke Barca
Chancellor mark Cargill councillor David
Curtis counts the new ever Eden
counselor John Fielding catch that
Edward pizza attached to bill Fleming
can suggest boy chick counselor jewel
Foreman candy in front you can stir
Jenny frantically accounts for Jackie
Harris thanks to Trevor Harvey
councillor Peter Henchard Sarah Finn
coach Lee Matt Jennings cannister Danny
Kendall councillor Christopher Mills
hence the Penn Yan O'Donnell transfer
and Perry
councillor Manuela put together
counselor John Riley attached with Nigel
rock against the Ian Fenton and catch
the Sara Otte copies thank you
point chilly agenda I now invite those
members and officers present to make
their declarations of interest to the
meeting if you have any Chairman I would
like to mention the fact that there are
a number of recommendations today that
involve delegating powers to officers
and although these are not personally
interested in to the regulations I would
like the matter to be recorded in the
minutes just for the sake of
transparency Thank You mr. Grafton does
anybody else have any declarations of
interest they wished occur thank you
how now move on to announcements and
firstly I would like to record the death
of former chairman and council council
of the Reverend never be ma who died
last week I will invite cars for our
next meeting to pay tribute to his
contribution to this council rather than
delay proceedings today I'd also like to
welcome our new counselor counselor
perfect Galia newly elected councillor
for Welford I'd like to thank David
Buckland Tony perks the senior
management team and every employee of
Stratford District Council whether
working from home and notably
the contacts under staff for their
continuing efforts to deliver the
services to our residents of businesses
from those working in house it is so
important to those vulnerable and
distressed to have somebody to turn to
and by being there as a continuation
than normal in these abnormal times you
are delivering that stability even if
you cannot deliver the answers that they
want I'd also like to thank all those
what
working in the district in particular
our health services and they were
supporting them in so many ways our food
retailers though and those providing the
essential services and their staff and
those volunteers are helping to support
those activities we're staffing the many
community groups across the district
helping those self-aligned by isolating
all those in need who are likewise
isolated I also like to thank the two
cities of food row and my shine who have
both offered to supply much needed
personal protection equipment for the
medical services in this district in our
time of need
we are currently through a counselor Joe
Baca in touch with the South Water
Foundation Trust as to how we can
fulfill that offer and I understand some
of the goods are already in transit to
London to be shipped up to us in
Stratford I'd like to mention there are
sent us there are central industries
that are desperately short of staff from
the health services through the food
delivery staff and the farmers who will
all be severely short of staff in the in
the coming months if you are fit and the
medical protocols allow you need to
volunteer to help they all need as much
help as we can give thank you ladies and
gentlemen I've now like to call upon the
leader of the cancer council council
Tony Jefferson fares announcements Thank
You chair I just want to give you all a
picture for how we are operating at the
moment every [ __ ] in you take authority
myself the deputy leader the chief
executive and deputy chief executive
have a conference call just so that we
are all on the same page in all kept up
to date we're all extremely busy and
under immense pressure
every evening there is a videoconference
with counselors who are members of the
cabinet forum this is informal but
enables us to get soundings and to get
feedback it's especially useful to get
feedback from the tween Hatters so we
have a clearer understanding of what's
happened at County using this group
we've put in place a buddy system to
ensure that all counselors are kept as
up-to-date as we can there's much
communication at the moment by video and
teleconferencing as an illustration last
Friday I was scheduled into five
separate conferences unfortunately
sometimes the technology doesn't work
which is unbelievably frustrating whilst
the government may make announcement it
takes time to work through and circulate
the how-to guidance and I hope people
will understand that and bear with us on
that it is a rapidly changing landscape
I think also cancers need to be very
clear we can't do everything all at once
no matter how much effort we put in we
will not be able to provide support to
every business organization and
individual this is despite as the
chairman said everyone in the council
working extremely hard and being
extremely flexible
I hope counselors will actually help
manage expectations we are focused on
the medical emergency however we are
very aware that once this phase is over
there'll be a very significant economic
and social challenge ahead there will
also be a very significant financial
challenge to the council our costs are
increasing rapidly and our income is
declining even more rapidly the good
news is we've just had 43 and a half
thousand in support from the central
government on a personal note I would
like to thank the deputy leader for his
help and support
also pay tribute to David Buckland and
Tony perks I will say this has been very
much a team effort finally how we just
like to say that as a council and as
counselors we are going to face some
very very significant challenges ahead
thank you Thank You leader I now call
upon the deputy chief exec to have Tony
perks for his announcements Thank You
chairman our chief executive David
Buckland is joining us today by video
link and I think David has a few words
you'd like to share with you first not
the companion instance remaining up to
that
thank you David I would echo what David
said the area I would just like to
update on is the emerging community hubs
scheme that is being put together which
is designed to shield our most
vulnerable residents details of this is
still being worked up but SDC is working
sort of closely with the National Health
Service central government and our
Warwickshire colleagues to ensure the
delivered scheme is delivered swiftly
and effectively it should start to
mobilised in the next week we've got
them thinking we're going to use the
letter Center as our local base
equipment is starting to arrive from
Monday and as and one of the needs and
the users of the schemes are identified
we will start rolling that as soon as we
possibly can but we're gearing up ready
for that sort of national members were
aware of what was going on thank you
thank you mr. parks we have two
questions
firstly from councillors unit can't just
to add my thanks to the staff just as
everybody else's done I really do
appreciate that I have appreciated the
clear information and guidance that I've
had from the chief executive because the
he's been able to put forward that
information in from government in a
clear format which is not always easy to
do so thank you very much David and
thank you to all the members of the
stuff from myself and my group I think
councils unit Costa Rolf Tony may I ask
you a question about the community hub
is that okay to ask a question about
that yeah could you could you just
elaborate a bit more on how that will
work is it just for delivering food to
vulnerable people and if it is obviously
when one's going to use a lot of
volunteer effort there and do we have
enough volunteer effort in place
thank you Thank You counselor op I will
it's a bit of an emerging picture but
I'll try and tell you what I what I know
what I believe to be true at the moment
I understand that the shielded scheme is
his design to protect the most
vulnerable in society the NHS have
identified between one and one and a
half million people who they think fall
into that category and they've been
contacted over the last few days by the
Department of Work and Pensions to find
out whether they need help or they've
got provisions in place from that a list
will be drawn up so as we've got names
and addresses throughout the country of
the people who need shielding by the
bias of us on the stage my understanding
is that the food industry have put
together a standard sort of food in
house of provisions parcel that will be
delivered to those people directly by
the food industry as a default where
local government will sort of come in is
a district level we will be asked to
pick up the slack for people whom this
under passed isn't suitable if that sort
of cultural religious dietary voluntary
type region reasons and for things that
don't quite work out well we find people
who've been perhaps missed off the list
or whether additional needs will be
attitudes of the service as almost as a
supplementary service to the main food
delivery network in terms of medicine at
the moment it's being proposed that's
delivered by through community
pharmacies but one of the sort of
possibilities is that once the
infrastructure is in place and once
we've got a delivery network in place we
might be able to sort of support things
like that depending on how the need
emerges as the pandemic develops at the
moment we don't really know the level of
demand because it depends on the
response we get to the one and a half
million people and sort of where they're
located and how many room more anxious
so we're we're gearing up the leisure
centre to be ready
Nosa say the equipment just starting
from Monday I've got stuff on standby a
lot of our staff as people like the
Building Control team that are used to
driving around the district and you've
got
fewer calls on that time than perhaps
there's some times have we've got them
in computer we've got some other
services queued up when we know the
quantum of demand we've also got a
network of volunteers being assembled
through Charles Barlow at the county
council so when we know the quantity
will work out what resource it is best
to use depend on what demands come upon
us but at the moment we're still not
quite clear what that is so if we're
trying to prepare for all scenarios
really could I could I I mean obviously
your keep us informed I mean I'm I'm
being kept in thought as a county
councillor but there's no detail around
it so as soon as you you hear anything
can you just update us please I'd be
very grateful
yeah one of the biggest frustrations is
because we're still gathering the
information I think it's central level
as to what's required we don't really
know what what we're dealing with but as
soon as we do and as soon as you need
anything I won't be hesitating and
asking councillor Crump Thank You Co
suppose it comes from
try again that's better I think it's
partly the nut said we got answered
coughs question Tony you said it was
going to supplement the mine food
deliveries from is that from other hubs
the Stratford one for special special
food needs such as vegan hello or
whatever is that the case or is it
coming out from Stratford to other parts
the I've particularly save them will you
be driving Suffolk to save them with
your Building Control people or are you
augment in the response from a hub
that's been provided by borax yeah this
is where I'm slightly confused as I
understand the main deliveries would
just come direct from the supermarket's
so the bulk of people be served from
there
as I understand anything within the
Stratford district will come from the
Stratford hub so it's been done once a
district boundary double so yes we would
be coming out from Stratford to say them
and run that from Stratford as the local
jet that mr. Buckland I think you wanted
to make a comment mr. Buckland we can't
hear
thank you thank you David did anybody
else have any issues they wish to raise
on the chief executive and deputy chief
executive statement if not we will move
on and we now move on to public
participation but in fact we've received
no questions from the public and there
are none present so that we can move on
to 0.5 as a standard item for those who
are watching after the election in word
and that is the political balance
calculation
all right the deputy chief executive to
introduce this item Thank You chairman
following the recent by-election in
welcome it has been necessary to update
the political balance calculation that
determines the allocation of seats from
the various committees of the council
you'll find on your tables in front of
you and a three sheets that sets out the
political balance cup dressing the
allocation of seats I would simply ask
you to note that at this stage council
Gennadiy when you when you look and take
take this and looking at it in more
detail could you take account of the
fact that the Liberal Democrats are
heavily over-represented on one of the
planning committee is planning a but
underrepresented quite quite a lot on
audit and standard given that the new
counselor will not be able to have
planning training for quite some time it
might make sense for her to be on the
Audit Committee rather than a planning
committee so if that could be looked at
and whether you know to adjust that to
make sure that there isn't problems with
planning committee I think it would make
sense
we can do that does anyone have any
further points they wish to raise on
political balance calculation no in
which case all we agreed it can be noted
thank you
we now move on to matters to the
dissemination of the council and I've
interned in monitoring officer to
introduce this item which is changes to
the Constitution arising out of the
current circumstances mr. Grafton would
you like to take on chairman prior to me
and addressing this report you'll notice
in the summary there is a question of
whether members are willing to make a
resolution to suspend council procedural
24.2 I don't know whether you want to
deal with that first
I think it would be wise to deal with
that first
thank you
following the request for monitoring
officer and the Commission's leader are
we happy to suspend procedure rule 24
point to all those agreed if I could
just give a very brief introduction to
this report given it's down in my name
this is about agreeing temporary changes
to the government's arrangement for
council meetings and processes for
making decisions in accordance with
government guidance and I want to make
it clear it is in line with government
guidance because of the self isolation
and social distancing we have to respond
to the medical emergency I have to say
that the details on this were changing
until late in the day it's also very
technical so I would like to hand over
to mr. Grafton to cover most of the main
points but I do assume that everybody
has read it thank you mr. Grafton Thank
You leader and so what I was going to do
if you have had an opportunity really is
just to focus on a few particular
paragraphs in the report so if we start
with paragraph one point two point one
this refers to the coronavirus bill and
I can confirm that the bill did receive
royal assent last night and therefore it
is now officially an act of Parliament
which will now give the Secretary of
State the power to make the necessary
regulations although of course those as
far as we know have not been produced as
yet paragraph one point four point three
I just need to make clear that the
procedure that is outlined in that
paragraph and we're talking about
contentious planning decisions only does
relate to contentious planning
applications that means that I am
proposing a very small tweak to appendix
1a to make that to make that clear
so that's not appendix 1:8 appendix 2a
just to make clear that it does refer to
contentious planning applications in
terms of the process under paragraph one
point four point three
turning now to paragraph one point five
point two I said in my report that I
would provide a short verbal update
about licensing we've done some research
on this and the number of license types
of licensing decisions that can be
delegated to me as head of governance
and democracy would be most types of
license other than premises licenses
under the licensing Act 2003 and also
issues under the gambling at nine 2005
so that means that most types of
licenses license matters can be
delegated to me including taxes this
brings me to the document that was
placed on your tables just before the
meeting started which is an option for
you to amend delegation 22 from appendix
to be to the report we just turn to
delegation 22 and you'll see on your
table that the the further
recommendation would be that the wording
highlighted in grey would be used as an
amendment I'll just read it out because
there are people who are watching this
that perhaps won't have the benefit of
seeing what that amendment was if the
amendment is accepted as on is in new on
your table it would read where there are
valid applications or representations
that are not withdrawn in
to a premises licensed under the
licensing at 2003 or a matter under the
gambling at 2005 the matter shall be
referred to the relevant committee or
panel in accordance with part 3 of the
Constitution in relation to any other
contested licensing matter the head of
governance and democracy shall have
authority to determine the matter that
extra change would be an extra rep
recommendation that I will call
recommendation 7 so that's another
matter for you to consider going back to
the paragraphs in the report paragraphs
one point five four to one point five
six we're talking about here the virtual
hearings for premises licenses and
gambling Act issues I just wanted to
make clear that when holding panels
virtually we will try to incorporate
access to those meetings on a similar
way to what we are doing generally with
physical meetings that of course is
subject to the technology allowing us to
be able to do that at paragraph one
point six this is in reference to
overview and scrutiny and particularly
calling I just want to make clear that
this applies to all executive decisions
whether made by the leader a member of
the cabinet or an officer decision that
relates to an executive function where
where necessary paragraph one point
eight point three I just wanted to
emphasize the fact that once the
regulations do come into force and
officers have had an opportunity to
consider the detail and access the
practical application of remote meetings
the chairman of the council might very
well be issuing a further note
perhaps to dis apply or loosen some or
all of the measures that are contained
within the recommendations those are the
points that I wanted to rave but I'm
happy to answer any individual questions
Thank You chairman just before I take
the two points can I confirm that
paragraph 1 point 4 point 2 has been
inserted since the original paper was
circulated yesterday and would you like
just to expand on that yes this was
subject to some discussion at the draft
stage of the report and it was drawn to
my attention that there should be an
opportunity for an applicant knowing
that the officer recommendation was was
probably going to be to refuse the
application for the applicant to
mutually agree with the local planning
authority to defer the application
perhaps to a point in time when planning
committees were able to meet as as they
are at the moment thank you mr. Grafton
council Junod yes if it had the Royal
Assent then presumably the secondary
legislation has now to kick in and that
would take a fair bit of time still
unfortunately that's the one thing so
just keep us informed on planning
decisions I think that's where you're
going to have a lot more of the
contentious issues to deal with so I
would ask you to consider I know that
the chief planning planner Steve
Quartermaine has asked for a very
innovative approach to be used and that
councils should be encouraged to explore
every opportunity to use technology or
whatever to ensure the discussions and
conversations can can go ahead as you
know that we as counselors are on the
front line when it comes to people
object making object
once the government has confirmed that
it will reintroduce the legislation to
allow committee meetings to be held
virtually then that can be dealt with at
that time but meanwhile I think it is
quite important that we do have and
allow all supporters objectors ward
members counselors to be able to see
everything that's coming through all
representations consultations as well as
the other officers report and as I
understand it the planning advisory
service is now pushing for a tight
timetable for the secondary regulation
to allow for virtual planning committees
as soon as the Royal Assent now that the
Royal Assent has been given but I just
fear that in the light in the gap
between now and when that assent is
given that some contentious issues could
come forward and that we could find
ourselves in a very difficult position
if we are not able to represent the
people in our wards Thank You Alec
student council rolled floors next I
know Council because the premise and
once I think to respond to that but it
would go in chronological order who
decides what is contentious and what
isn't contentious I mean it's it is a
gray area
it worries me enormous Lee because are
you going to look at you know perhaps a
neighbor either side of an application
that's really upset about you know an
extension I mean is that contentious is
it not contentious are we looking at
large developments obviously large
developments could be very contentious
who makes that decision can we as Ward
members put a plea to Robert weeks to
say look you know we feel that there's
enough objection or enough support will
I mean in other words who is gonna make
that decision and what is contentious
and what
mr. gralton yeah that's a very good
point and one that we have considered
carefully if you look to paragraph one
point four point three what it says in
the report is that we've used a
definition actually which is from the
existing delegated powers and we're
defining it as one where the head of
planning and housing in consultation
with the chairman of a planning
committee believes that the application
has generated significant public
interest or in any other respect merits
it being considered as a contentious
matter I do appreciate that that is
something that is extremely difficult to
define I really do and we have struggled
with that but that's the best that we've
come up with and as I say does it is a
copy virtually from one of the existing
features in that delegation sorry Robert
weeks yes as I say in consultation with
the chairman of Planning Committee yes
Kempton
Thank You chairman the question of
planning applications he's one that
exercises all members in this new
reality and most of our residents the
clear fear that something contentious
will somehow be slipped under the radar
and then the first thing to say is that
we have a very bright set of officers
who understand the culture of this
Authority and the extent to which
members and our residents value their
input into planning applications and the
head of planning and housing and is not
going to be deaf to those things in the
new regime the other point that I think
is worthy of note is
in reality a number of what may be
contentious applications are not
actually going to be able to proceed
for example many applications require
specific technical reports that can only
be achieved by on-site investigations
there is only so much you can do with
drones there is only so much that you
can do remotely so I think that the
there will be naturally some drying up
because the applicants and the consul
teas and indeed our officers may not be
able to bring these matters forward so
that even where a decision was made by
the head of planning and housing in
conjunction with the chair that those
decisions might not actually be ready to
be made I think probably the closest
applications are the ones for the
planning committee that was cancelled a
week or so ago I was probably the
closest that there are to shovel-ready
they won't stop entirely but it is
difficult to see how for example you
know major applications of many hundreds
of houses can significantly progress
given the restrictions on all of the
consul teas so I think that to try and
give some comfort to all members - to
those watching this that it may well
actually prove to be less of an issue
one suspects however that the planning
team may well be significantly busier in
the Bulge after all of this thing
Council Jefferson Thank You chair I
think we all have to accept that the
moment we are in some pretty unique
circumstances I think we have to have a
degree of trust that we will attempt to
do things in the right way and deal with
things flexibly and the whole thrust of
this is to enable they work of the
council to continue so I hope members
will actually
look at it in that light Thank You
counselor do not just on behalf of
councillor Nigel rocky he has put
forward some suggestions I do want to
mention that he has to put those forward
and that they will be considered but on
a separate issue if you don't mind on
that further on which is one point eight
point four I did mention making it clear
about the corona various bill but can I
also ask that that though that this bill
says that local authorities you know
there is a definite deadline to when we
will go back to normal functioning in
the interest of democracy are obviously
if there is can be done sooner than that
it shall be done sooner than that mr.
cotton absolutely one of my titles is
head of governance and democracy and any
any reduction in democracies just you
know something that is apparent to me
but we have this health emergency of
course councillor Bromwich yeah the
whole everything sounds pretty
reasonable but I do have a bit of
concern about whether contentious issues
come out and the fact that I think also
award members will be consulted along
with the actual planning chairman and
the head of planning which votes that
she mentioned in there so I know
certainly I've got an application which
would have gone before the last Planning
Committee which would have been very
contentious and possibly had caused a
lot of public speakers and obviously the
current circumstance they're not going
to be speaking in public and it could be
very impractical for us to set up links
to people's homes everywhere and I think
at times now we haven't have to look at
this sort of thing what we do have to
use a bit of common sense all to this
we're three parts of sit down it has
been massive objections for an
application well we might have to say
well it would've gone before the
Planning Committee how
at this point in time it's appropriate
due to circumstances it goes before the
committee that's not the sub my but it
could be anybody's application that I
know it counts the rock bench you've got
contentious one coming potentially
forward so I think sometimes we will
have to we agree informally that we
might have to have some consultations
and we might have to turn around and say
let's apply some common sense until we
get over what or we get a new regime
where we can work better than what we
are at the moment transform which can I
just pick up that point if you go to
appendix 2a under subparagraph 19 a the
ward member and or the parish or Town
Council will be permitted to put their
case to the head of Planning and housing
so that is built into the amendment that
has been proposed by mr. Grafton the
Constitution so in those situations
which you're discussing we are actually
putting in writing that requirement does
that satisfy you
yes that's my waiter I was looking for
it so anybody watching does have a
general clarification because obviously
they're not going to be reading what
we've got in front of us so it's very
good for the council to clarify things
to those who are watching on YouTube at
the moment thank you Castle Bromwich
council Richards Thank You chair arias
right something the leaders said that we
are in an unprecedented times we do have
to move quickly we do have to think
outside the box and ways we can deal
with the normal functioning of this
authority that is exactly what we're
looking at here I think it's eminently
sensible that we go ahead with what has
been proposed in front of us in order to
maintain the safe secure operations of
this council from an overview and
scrutiny perspective clearly there's an
element of I've change for for that
committee I want to give some
reassurance first of all the members of
the committee of also members of the
council and the public that we will
continue to operate as best we can
in normal circumstances where it comes
to call in which is really the only
decision making power that the scrutiny
committee has clearly that what set out
is a way in which the that scrutiny
committee through myself as chairman can
continue to operate make decisions the
reassurance I want to give is that where
if that happens I certainly have every
intention and the facilities and ability
to be able to have either resume a team
or a Skype meeting a group meeting where
we can operate and make decisions and
that rapport can then be written up by
me confirmed by the vice-chair before
it's been submitted so I just want to
make sure everyone is aware and
comfortable that is a situation I also
want to say to residents that if there
are issues that they want to raise we
are still open to be talked to my
contact details are on our website so if
you want to email me or phone me and
discuss things particularly around
scrutiny a lot of things please do the
two questions I have within the report
we're we're seeking to change the
calling to restrict adjusted key
executive functions within the
appendices we have an extract from
article 13 of the Constitution there's
no real change to that article I don't
see where there's a change being made to
the Constitution and I having looked
through the various elements also
Constitution around to scrutiny I don't
see where I may be missing this but I
don't see where we need to make that
change do we need to make a change to
the Constitution or is this report
sufficient to allow for those executive
sort of key executive decisions as we
cordoned and also almost to a point that
the council June had made earlier on
when we get to unwind all this how does
that process happen is it quite simply a
back to business as usual a full council
we need you to confirm these changes
back to normal is it as simple as that
or is there more to it two questions for
you mr. Grafton from council Richards
so in respect of what changes are there
in the rules there are in effect a
number of different changes one is about
key decisions because at the moment
under the rules you can call in any
decision it doesn't just have to be a
key decision for that's one change
secondly in relation to the way that
calling works at the moment of course it
it triggers a meeting of the committee
and as you'll see in that part of the
report it's suggesting another means of
achieving the views of the committee
without actually a physical meeting as
you've just described and those are the
those are the suggested changes
otherwise that the rules remain in place
and as far as the future is concerned
and I suppose this applies to all the
other recommendations too but of course
the moment that health risks start to
reduce or are completely eliminated and
this particular rule as with the other
recommendations will be kept constantly
under review by the chairman of the
Council and he will be taking advice
from the leaders of the two political
groups as well and if Matt has changed
then he the chairman of the council will
be issuing a further notice
and I fully expect that recommendations
such as this that the measures within
them will be relaxed or eliminated it is
all geared to the level of public health
risk really at the end of the day up to
that chaired so on a latter point I
understood coincides with my thinking as
well so I'm entirely comfortable with
that as long as it we can and will
approach that as soon as possible after
we're a little pandemic specifically
about the changes so as I say I'm not
I've no issue with the changes they've
been proposed for it scrutiny and indeed
for licensing and
banning within the licensing a planning
there's clear constitutional change I
don't see clear constitutional change
forever in scrutiny I want to make sure
that we are getting the wording right
and in the right places could you please
confirm what element of the Constitution
needs changing you'll appreciate that
this report that's been put together has
been done completely on the hoof and I'm
sorry but we just have not had the time
to go through the rules in the way that
we normally would and earmark by way of
gray highlighting and crossing through
which which which parts of the rules
will be suspended and I'm hoping that
that members will give us allowance for
that and and take the recommendations as
set out in 1.6 on face value I'm taking
it on face value for the purposes of
today but what I would request 9 and I
hope that I'll get support from most of
the members is that as chair of Obion
scrutiny I get to see what's being
changed and confirm it before officially
that that changes official if that's
okay and hopefully everyone also support
perhaps when all this is over
undone then maybe over in scrutiny
committee could just have a review of
the whole process from beginning to end
Thank You counselors unity casa
Jefferson I think as I said earlier
we're facing some quite unique
circumstances I take exactly the point
that mr. Grafton made we are in a very
fast changing environment we have to
respond quickly and if this is not all
the eyes dotted and all the t's crossed
nevertheless it makes a perfectly
acceptable way forward for the council
can I urge members to actually accept
all the recommendations one to seven
please I think guys
ladies and gentlemen members I take on
board council Richards requests but that
would seem to pose potentially in a
position where if for whatever reason
there was something that councillor
Richards was not content with we either
make the decision on the recommendations
or we don't as far as I can see and I'm
looking for some guidance from mr.
Grafton about it would seem I think we
either take this on face value or
alternatively it would seem that we're
asking the chair is asked of the
overview and scrutiny committee he's
asking for an opportunity to review and
potentially amend now but that would put
us in a really difficult position
because we have brought people together
to do this face to face because we are
obliged to get these decisions done face
to face and I think it would be I would
be uncomfortable with the position that
could end up with us having to be here
again
to put this into effect I think for me
it is clear
that the Kirlian applies to the key
decisions that are defined in appendix
three and i have item six on page 15
unless I'm missing something mr. Grafton
and you can help me with it but I'm
uncomfortable with something that might
open us up to having to be coming back
here again and we do have to exercise
some discretion here and have some faith
in the what our officers have put
together it is inconceivable to me that
we would make any decision that sort of
go as wildly off the reservation or
wildly out of or even mildly out of what
is the clear intention here to allow for
scrutiny of the of the key decisions so
I'm perhaps looking for mr. Grafton to
give me some help here because I do
think we need to get a resolution to
this thing today mr. Graff and would you
like to come back and then pick up more
comfortable coins yes I think I think
that's exactly the point
Castle fan impotent as you've just
explained counselor our bond which I
think was rich as I know you want to
come back yeah I think we are the
situation now well we gotta be realistic
this ain't gonna be permanent it's
temporary let's face it you're not going
to gain the absolutely perfect in the
speed that we've had to move their thing
but what such been drawn up as from what
I've read through there I think we've
got to go with it and I would actually -
I'll say the suit we voted through the
batter on it and bear in mind everybody
this is only temporary when we get past
this stage we can have a proper look our
Constitution there's parts we might want
to keep those parts we might not we can
decide in the future but we need to act
for them now we need to get this done we
need to give the public confidence that
we make firm decisions thank you council
JUnit I think all we need to do is add
to number five that the the review it
just can't consults with the chairman of
overview and scrutiny
as we go through I don't think it meet
needs any major changes to the consulate
to the the decision-making process etc
it just means making sure that the
chairman of overviewed scrutiny is kept
in the loop are you making a proposal to
amend so could you define exactly so we
have a correct record exactly what
wording you wants putting into paragraph
five of the recommendation please
it says the recommendation set out the
requirements set out in recommendations
one to four to be subject to ongoing
review by the chairman of the council in
consultation with the chief executive
the leader of the council and the leader
of the authorization opposition and with
the chairman of the ovn scrutiny
committee and then it carries on and by
reference to etc the chairman of the OSC
has seconded that I assume he's
comfortable with that amendment mr. Graf
no you happy with that
inclusion I'm completely comfortable
with that yes right we'll come back to
verging on that shortly because I just
want to make sure we wrap up on on the
anybody else who is surfing I think
council Jefferson you had one point to
make exactly what counsel Abramovich
said I think we've got to demonstrate
common sense I think we've got to be
very pragmatic and this is only going to
be temporary so I think we should
actually accept this now council krub
when Katie Pemberton actually mentioned
a branch sort of planning he's gonna say
planning jamming but unfortunately
didn't Bob see moving on we are those
plan Chairman we see him regularly
correspondence emails from objectives
from supporters etc and I've done image
that changing so therefore we will have
some idea some flavor of whether it's
going to be a contentious one we do get
spoken to by other members and I'm sure
I'll catch the candles cherub funding I
will be lighting Wrigley with Roberts as
head of planning and housing and we will
be as pragmatic practical as possible
but we also try and challenge
constructively so I think the checks and
balances will be there and if you've
ever watched the Planning Committee we
have trouble keeping one or two members
under control but might be wanted to
hear today but we won't mention them but
we do try and challenge we try and be
fair and reasonable and try and give
people the chance to make their points
and put them across so therefore I can't
see that changing and I'm sure I will
work very well with mr. weeks Thank You
council Richards thank you as I said I
think the proposals within this
eminently sensible and I've got no issue
with them in principle just to come back
to the pending made we're being asked to
make a change to our Constitution that
we would not normally be asked to make a
change without sight of the wording and
that's the point I was trying to make
I've got no issue with what's being
contained in here and I've got no issue
with our officers being more than
capable and competent and getting it
right but clearly we're being asked to
make a change without sight of the
change that was the issue of trying to
raise the amendment that has been
proposed 2.5 is ultimately what I was
trying to say wouldn't I spoke earlier
with that in place then I absolutely see
that we can move forward this I don't
see in a position where we're coming
back here and saying actually that
wording is not quite right we need to
reach ange it this can be dealt with
outside
that amendment and I'm entirely happy
with it with that J if I can propose
that we now move to a vote and get this
done thank you okay thank you everybody
for those contributions I think they've
been so did you have a it's been a
constructive exchange of ideas if we
just look at the planning one concerns
were raised about ward members parish
members representing the views the
appendix to does clearly say that the
head of planning and housing will
consult with ward members and parish
councils so there is that protection for
residents the second area is on the
other side is the applicant now we are
required to determine an application
with a certain time scale and as the
paper sets out if the applicant believes
that the application is going to be
refused he can request a deferral for it
to go to committee cleave that will that
will allow the council to let that
determination date to slip so I think
both sides are properly represented the
community and an applicant and a
contentious application in terms of
Licensing I don't think any issues have
been raised on the licensing issues and
the only issues that we have raised on
the OSC changes we have an amendment
proposed by council June 8th to include
the the words the head of the chairman
oversee and that has been seconded and I
think that really wraps up the nature of
the debate we've had if anybody feels
I've missed anything else out please say
so sorry mr. graphical georgous sorry
chairman it's just to say that when we
were discussing delegation 22 which is
the licensing one a copy of which you've
got on the desk that in fact does
constitute an extra recommendation so
that's recommendation to seven
thank you so we have a set we have seven
recommendations hopefully I summarized
nobody has expressed concern with my
summary so what I'm good desire to move
forward to the vote now there are any I
think nine of us see I can't count that
quickly sorry but these are fundamental
changes I'm going to ask to go through
each one very quickly I'm not going to
ask necessary for show of hands unless
there is contention on it but just a
vote on each one separately rather than
take them on block because this is a
fundamental change of the Constitution
and I think everybody needs to
particularly those watching live or on
the subsequent broadcast that each one
has been considered by the
representative the council here today so
I'm going to start off a numerical order
I will come to the amendment when we get
to pay and it's a recommendation five so
if we can start off with recommendation
one our are we all agreed with
recommendation one that's unanimous
recommendation to licensing are we
agreed recommendation three overview and
scrutiny committee procedure rules are
we agreed
recommendation for are we agreed
recommendation five we have the
amendment to the proposal which is to
include the words the chairman of OSC
after the words leader of the opposition
are we agreed to that proposal yeah
everybody agreed thank you
we therefore go back to 5:00 as a whole
are we we've had an amendment can we
accept this proposal as amended thank
you
we move on to point six that the
chairman of the council has authority to
publish further notice etc are we agreed
and then the additional proposal which
is enumerated as number seven which is
delegation 22 as identified by the
monitoring officer are we agreed
for that thank you very much
I will just add the modern officer
mentioned on a number of occasions that
this will be in consultation with the
Chairman and if any member present or
not present has any concerns about any
issues and the way things are developing
I do have the right to call an
extraordinary meeting as I did to this
one and it will be at my discretion
clearly but I will do so in consultation
with the leader and the leader of the
opposition but if anybody has any
concerns about the operation of these
changes going forward I will undertake
to review those concerns along with the
head of paid service sorry the the the
chief executive the deputy chief
executive the monitoring officer and the
the two leaders I will give you that
guarantee so which case we can draw a
close on that element of the agenda
thank you all for those constructive
comments and we therefore move on to
item 7 and I invite the leader of the
council to introduce this item Thank You
chair this is a matter for noting by the
council and in a way it matters the
previous announcement this is to make an
amendment to enable continue to the
executive business and decision making
as an interim measure and I would stress
that during the corona virus pandemic
and this is really about continuity and
speed so with that council this is for
noting
Thank You counselor Richard she was
quite happy with it I'm pleased to see
there's consultation with both leader of
the Opposition and with overview and
scrutiny I think that's very sensible
from on your part what I would say again
it's similar to the previous is when we
come to unwind this presumably this will
be I mean I know it's down to your
discretion but this will be delivered at
the same time as unwinding the previous
changes as Constitution I just want that
under taking from you from now
absolutely correct counsel Richards
Topman Thank You councillor JUnit I know
that this is the leaders and noticeably
the decision but just to want to be
clarified about the the issues that were
on the paper by urgent decisions in
relation to the initial response to Cove
in nineteen which has about agrees to
the delays on the chargeable garden
waste service when what when are we
taking that decision mr. perks would you
like to respond to catch the Junior's
question yes at the end of the meeting
they did Thank You counsel Rolf
are there any further questions on the
leaders statement in which case can we
all take that as noted please we
therefore now move on to item 8 urgent
business which has been approved by me
to go forward
I'd like the deputy chief executive to
introduce this item if I may I would
just like to sorry leader your use for
the old chief deputy detective
they come with my name on them in which
case the council Jefferson please
continue sorry about that
okay as we've already said throughout
this meeting this pandemic has changed
the environment in which we work in we
have to review the way in which we can
operate at least in the short term the
report before you today considers three
things
two of these matters related to
decisions made by the council within
past six months the council rushed to
suspend procedure rule 17 1 and 17 2
pursuant to rule 24 1 so collapse
Council to do that please are we all
agreed
following the request from the leader
that we also suspend council procedure
rules 7.17 point 1 and 17.2 pursuant to
council cathedral 24.1 are we agreed
thank you carry on council Jefferson
Thank You counselor has to agree delay
the implementation of chargeable worst
service until March 20 21 and delay the
implementation of the driver's car
parking charges until the day not before
the 1st of April 20-21 counselor also
asked to provide delegation to the
council's chief exec to allow the
council to act expeditiously in the
current pandemic circumstances
are some things I would just like to
pick up in this report they in 162 net
loss of income 350,000 in section 172
loss of income 270,000 what I will say
is that at the moment our costs are
rising rapidly our income is
deteriorating rapidly and there are
calculations going on at the moment
about the impact on the council the
reality is that by the time we get
through to 2021
we will be facing a very different
environment to 2019 there will be some
very serious issues about council
funding by then that's why we are
deferring these issues Thank You counsel
Jefferson - thank you I just wanted to
bring in something for consideration
which is the LGA saying that many counts
authorities supporting critical workers
in this way by suspending charges in car
parks we have a situation in Stratford
that the Town Council the town trust
working to to have a lot of volunteers
who will be going to the local shops in
Stratford to pick up food parcels and
prescriptions etc and we also have key
workers working in those shops food
shops and I wondered whether this
council would consider suspending any
car parking charges in the British foot
carpark for those key workers and for
those people that are picking up
emergency supplies for our most
vulnerable thank you Justin could I just
ask the question of mr. perks please if
we formally suspend the car parking
charges does that mean we have to give
refunds
I think if we were to formally suspend
all car pink car parking charges that
weren't even plication to season tickets
and I also think that would probably
send the wrong message because it would
be encouraging people into ten at a time
we're saying people shouldn't socially
gather what we could do what we are
already doing with the NHS is looking at
is there a way that we could identify
key groups who are sort of assisting in
the delivery of this emergency operation
and perhaps provide some sort of pass or
concession for them rather than
suspending car parking all together that
would be that would probably be a in my
opinion a better way to do it
Karl Rove I appreciate that
however we are in unprecedented times
and a lot of the workers in for instance
on Bridge Street at mark Spencer's
Sainsbury's and Tesco's are working flat
out they're working very very long hours
and they're doing all they can to
provide food parcels and I just wondered
whether just for those workers that are
working in that particular industry you
could allow them that pass within the
bridge foot car park now it may be that
they already have I doubt it though
parkland staff couldn't afford the 500
pounds a year really but I wondered if
we could look at that sympathetically
place because of Pemberton I think there
is a balance between being agile and
trying to make things up on the fly I
think you've had the message that
there's a desire to try and find a way
to make this happen
I think let's let's give the officers
sort of 24 hours or so to operationalize
it because we're not going to come to an
agreed scheme here and now I think
there's an acceptance that we need to
find a way
support the volunteers and those who
were who are actually helping society
recover from this crisis and they don't
they don't they're not disadvantaged
let's let's task the officers with
coming back and they'll update myself
and the leader and then we can feedback
through as soon as we can
can Imay absolutely clear councillor
Ralph I am pretty sure that mr. perks
actually said we would look at that
flexibly and consider a way of doing it
Thank You councillor baggage little
points that so we are turning around
saying we're going to try and make drugs
available less so to support local
community and economy I know already
there's some people in privy to some
emails from me in particular about this
sort of issue and now so when we start
getting some formulated ideas that can
we make sure who circulated onto this
part as a general and secondly as part
of this can we now popular record that
councillor who are not here as well as
this here can they start putting some
suggestions in and can we have a central
focal point for those suggestions and
that on things like grants for local
community and economy I think if we have
a go to a person it will make this lot
better then as I've seen off council
pamphlets and earlier than a few of us
they're circulating about absolutely
everybody all in and tag no solid and
getting bombarded by emails it's a lot
easier to talk one focal point and try
not to make as well that are poor
officers here as well in particular who
are working 24/7 that know pretty much
i'm also overloaded so I think we could
probably find some sort of designated
person within the organization
thank you can serve orange I mean any
councillor has the authority at any
stage to contact any officer in this
organisation clearly
the senior officers are fantastically
busy at the moment
but I'm sure mr. Buckland and mr. parks
will take away or suggestion and if they
can find a sort of accounts or email
request type email address code unit can
I say that I support the the delay foot
to the implementation of the chargeable
garden waste service and as amended on
as the flexible scheme that will come
forward on the revised car parking
charges and I also agree about making
such grants that are necessary to
support the local community in economy
what I would ask is that that the on the
council's website but also on the phone
messages that are at them out there that
there is clear and on a big ambiguous
messages to people to ring up so you
know that it is quite clear exactly what
is being offered because there is still
a lot of uncertainty about the changes
can I also thank the officers for their
clarity on a question that asked about
making sure that there is the council
deals with homelessness and that it
deals with food bank vouchers I have had
satisfactory answers on those and thank
you very much to that but it is most
important that people just get clear
messages council pemberton
sorry Jefferson easily confused yeah can
I can I just say that picking picking up
earlier points that are being made in a
lot of cases we will actually be passing
on money that is provided by central
government we are waiting for clarity on
a lot of those and it is most
unfortunate but as and when clarity
arises believe me we will act as swiftly
as we can so thank you for that and with
that can I propose that we accept
recommendations one two three on the
paper
thank you okay so that concludes item
eight there are no items on the agenda
ladies and gentlemen I would however
like to reassure everybody listening
that would they be those of the public
all those counselors aren't present that
officers are doing their utmost to
support the entire district supported by
the leader and the deputy leader and and
the leader the opposition during this
very difficult time I just like to pay
particular thanks at the moment to the
three officers who haven't been
mentioned Alex Eden list of Oscar and
Olivia Quinn who've attended this
meeting now most people are working from
home so I'd like to give our thanks as
committee for them turning out it's not
not a good time to be traveling so thank
the three of you very much that point
ladies and gentlemen and there are no
other items I'm going to close this
meeting before I do I look forward to
seeing you all again and as soon as
possible time
let's hope it is not too long and mr.
Platts of course is also in the room
with us so thank you David as well for
your contribution and for those senior
members the management team who are on
screen that we can see but the members
of public
probably can't there's gentlemen thank
you I conclude the meeting